say something nice about the other
person
uh he's got great teeth oh there we go i
agree i saw him look at his look at his
face right now he's like this is a hard
one very hard i'm still trying to figure
it out
come on you got to say something i am
speechless uh maybe talk about it the
first time okay with a microphone in
front of my face i am speechless wow
would you guys fight jake paul
for enough money if if would you fight
jake paul if you could win another major
oh oh yeah yeah oh that's a quick yeah
okay
but yeah
okay would you fight jake paul brycey
look
if if it paid enough yes i would
that's the answer oh that's the game of
golf it's all about money i love it love
that energy he's such a strong
individual that nothing can break phil
there's just nothing i've tried for
years to get into his head and it just
bounces right off it's impossible maybe
take out one of the 17 chemicals in his
coffee
[Laughter]
i'm the only one here who's won a major
this
year why did they choose 12 holes is
because it's just you guys would be too
exhausted or what's the reason for that
they wanted to give bryson a chance to
beat his back 9 score at the u.s open
[Laughter]
i'm getting word from the director that
was a little too mean
i don't know it's good oh i'm totally
comfortable with it okay i recognize
this stuff happens somehow i mean when
you miss cuts too you gotta have some
firepower it's just bad luck bad luck
you